speaking from my own experience and the
experience of countless others that I've
had conversations with about
turning a negative into a positive
making the most out of moments of
adversity the thing that that helped
them was them
was deciding to change who they were
deciding to change the course of their
life and I think when we've experienced
hardship growing up or we've dealt a bad
hand we've developed this mindset where
we feel like we're owed all this stuff
the reason I think it's so important
is because when you relinquish control
and power onto somebody else you lose
because now you're putting all your
hopes into things you can't control and
it's in the stuff that you're really
powerless over and you're essentially
just giving away any responsibility or
accountability and then you feel like
the world is against you and owes you
things and I think you'll start to
behave in that way I think just really
getting good at mastering these mental
prisons that we live in when we are in
dark times is the way to win the reality
is like things change
and you just have to take it day by day
week by week and just take small steps
and keep celebrating those small wins
right and just to keep putting one foot
in front of the other and even though
you can't see light right now even
though it seems like really really dark
in your situation and the world seems
against you just keep moving forward one
step at a time one day at a time and
then I don't know when I don't know how
but light will come light will come but
you just have to keep believing in
yourself and focus on how far you've
come and not how far you have to go
that was Doug Bops an award-winning
personal trainer author speaker and
business owner who's changed countless
lives from his message of using your
disadvantages to your advantage and
overcoming anything in life Doug is a
former drug addict and convicted felon
who found transformation while serving
jail time he turned to drugs at 14 years
old as a way to cope with an emotionally
dysfunctional and broken home life
including abuse severe bullying and the
challenges that come with parents of
divorce this led him down a spiral of
addiction and selling drugs and he was
eventually pulled over and caught with
drugs in his car what seemed like the
worst day of his life turned out to be
his greatest blessing Doug used jail
time to transform himself both
physically and mentally he has now been
sober for over a decade and is the
author of three personal development
books including from Felony to Fitness
to free and is host of the podcast the
adversity Advantage his story is living
proof that even the most challenging of
experiences can lead to personal growth
success and transformation in life I'm
all about mindset being a key to
overcoming adversity and empowering
ourselves from victim to Victor how we
think about ourselves as a strong
determinator of our reality Doug speaks
a powerful message in this conversation
and I hope you find inspiration from
this episode and harness The Power
Within you so let's get into it welcome
to the Ellen Fisher podcast welcome to
the podcast Doug I am excited for this
conversation and I'm excited for you to
be able to share your story that has
impacted so many people
um so firstly before you get into that
can you share a little bit about like
what made you become so passionate about
sharing your story to help others Ellen
thanks for thanks for having me and it's
I know this has kind of been a long time
coming we've been going back and forth
for a little while trying to make this
work and I just wanted to thank you once
again for having me on with everything
that you have uh going on in your world
and
I guess for me like the main reason that
I've been so passionate about sharing my
story
is because like back in I guess it was
like 2018
2019 like right around that time frame
the drug epidemic here in the United
States was horrible like before the
pandemic like the main talk in the news
was the opioid epidemic and people were
overdosing left and right from heroin
fentanyl painkillers like everything
hasn't it only gotten worse too or do
you feel like I don't I haven't kept up
enough with it but yeah I mean obviously
I think the pandemic has caused some
repercussions in that field like when
people I think people were it was harder
for people to get access to see a
psychiatrists and get treatment and then
you had people that were stressed about
finances they were stressed emotionally
they were stressed mentally and then you
throw in like isolation and you're not
able to to be in community you're not
able to go where you want there's all
this uncertainty and fear which for many
people is the main reason why they get
hooked on drugs in the first place is
because they can't deal with the
discomfort that life brings so it's it's
an easy win to numb out
with drugs sometimes so
you know a few years ago I saw like
headlines all over the place and I had a
lot of friends that were impacted by
this
and my route
as far as getting into recovery was not
was pretty non-traditional
like I was in jail on felony drug
charges when I just when I decided that
I wanted to to transform my life and and
not use drugs again and then I got out
of jail and Health Fitness changing my
my friends changing my environment
personal development
um you know spirituality came a little
bit later but like a goal setting was
important to me as well like like those
those things were something that was
kind of unique in that I implemented
these things and I didn't go to AAA
didn't go to n a uh didn't go to
treatment and I'm not against any of
that it just wasn't my path I was kind
of scared straight from going to jail
and I also had this
I guess they call it like a spiritual
awakening like when I was there where I
had this aha moment that I finally had
some develop some self-confidence some
self-esteem
um this this discipline that I never had
through
um getting into health and fitness when
I was when I was incarcerating I know
we'll get into that in a minute but
with that said
I was like man like if health and
fitness and changing your friends and
believing in yourself more and having
some faith in your life if all these
things have worked for me to help
recover from addiction and improve my
mental health like I I bet there's
others
that can relate to this because from
what I understood at the time
the 12-step programs which again I think
helped so many people and I have nothing
against them that was like that's like
that was like the main form of of
treatment and recovery for a lot of
people and a lot of people I think felt
that it was either go to AAA or n a and
go to these meetings or like there was
nothing else
and so I wanted to share that like
listen like there's a lot of parallels
that exist between the way I did it and
the aana but here are some things that I
believe
are crucial
to thriving in recovery and it started
again with health and fitness changing
who you spend time with being goal
oriented
having some gratitude in your life
getting spiritual and having like this
immense level of self-awareness and the
reason that I thought my story was so
powerful was because
like I think one of the biggest mistakes
people make when they get into recovery
is they don't figure out how to develop
healthy coping mechanisms
and they don't learn how to deal with
the underlying root pain trauma
circumstances whatever it was that led
to their Addiction in the first place
and so I wanted to help inspire people
to use things like health and fitness to
use things like Community to use things
like spirituality purpose meaning to be
able to not only deal with a lot of the
stuff that weighed them down that led
them to drug addiction
um but also use that to really thrive in
a way that they weren't just getting
sober people were getting healthy so
that's in a nutshell like why I thought
my story was so unique
and it was it was powerful enough that I
thought I needed to stand up and have a
voice and start talking about it and
you know initially it's tough to share
your story right especially
with something like mine where I was a
convicted felon uh car straight on
felony drug charges I had a horrific
drug addiction
um I was depressed anxious Suicidal
Thoughts damaged relationships never had
a girlfriend in high school torn
relationships with my family 21 jobs at
the age of 21 like I go on and on with
all the the baggage in my life and you
sometimes sit there and you wonder like
if I put this all out there like am I
ever gonna get married
you know what everybody will anybody
ever like take me seriously in Life or
like what are my friends gonna say
what's my family gonna say
and I really had to come to terms I know
you are good about like speaking your
truth and like like owning like what you
talk about and it's just like you accept
you accept that for what it is and then
you just don't let the opinions of
others bother you in that
like I had to really get crystal clear
with with the fact that people who were
going to kind of kind of [ __ ] on me for
sharing what I shared and judging me
based on my past we're just not meant to
be in my life in my future
mm-hmm yeah that's absolutely a huge
part of it and I can imagine on top of
that like seeing such a transformation
in your own life and looking around and
being like why aren't people talking
about this we need to I need to get this
out there and then coming to term with
yourself about like what's this going to
look like for me to be vulnerable and
put myself out there and it really is
just a stepping stone that over time it
makes you stronger and I think it really
does it's helped me over the years you
know putting myself out there and just
sharing what I'm passionate about or
what I want to talk about you know just
being able to handle like other people
are going to have their opinions at the
end of the day like that's okay that's
that's on that's all right with them
they're allowed to have their opinions
and you can have your own opinions yeah
and I think it's you got to start small
you know it's not like
I just woke up one day and I appeared on
some like big podcast or a big media
Outlet like the next day you know I
think it just started with me starting
to organically share it like locally
here with even like some of my personal
training clients speaking to groups at
schools
um even like doing uh some local media
here getting featured in the newspapers
here that gave me I mean again it gives
you like the self-confidence and
affirmation that you're heading heading
the right way like if nobody aligned
with my story here and they were like I
like it's all good like the fitness
thing just doesn't matter like you know
everybody's parents are divorced like
everybody gets bullied you know it gets
bullied in school like I don't care like
it doesn't matter then I would have been
like yeah well maybe like speaking and
sharing my story maybe it's just not
that relatable but the opposite happened
almost it was almost shocking like how
much people related to my story and
would come up to me and like just talk
about how much it impacted them and I
still to this day it just feels kind of
funny to me because and not not that I
don't think I have achieved something
great because I obviously I think what
I've been able to overcome
is is Meaningful
but
I just always I've always seen myself as
just a regular person just having a
regular conversation
and like even like today like I don't
have an agenda like I'm just here to
serve I'm here to just share openly and
authentically to help your audience and
I think that's why people have have
really begun to relate to me in that I'm
not I'm not I don't have bullet points
I'm not like here to sell a product I'm
just just here essentially just to sell
hope
yeah well okay so let's back up a little
bit can you share with everybody
listening or watching
your story your childhood what led you
to using drugs as a coping mechanism
just explain and elaborate like your
history your background right so as I
kind of hinted at
um a few minutes ago and why I was so
passionate about sharing my story it's
because I I wanted to help inspire
people to not only get into recovery or
get into sobriety but also find new
tools and coping mechanisms
to deal with the reason that they chose
to use drugs in the first place or what
led them to their addiction and the
reason I'm passionate about that
is because growing up I did the opposite
and I as I look back
I look I I was clearly just trying to
escape
I was trying to escape I was trying to
run away from a lot of the pain and the
trauma that I was facing and with the
pain and Trauma looked like for me was
um I didn't have a girlfriend at all in
grade school my parents got divorced
when I was five and it was a very rough
divorce I was bullied in school I was
picked on I was told that I looked like
I had Down syndrome when I was in grade
school and and that really brought me
down so I started to develop this what's
wrong with me mentality because my
parents were getting divorced at a time
where I'm 30 I'll be 35 here in a few
months where this is nearly 30 years ago
where the divorce rate isn't wasn't
nearly as high as it is now so I was one
of the only kids in my friend group
whose parents were divorced and I was
having to spend time at different places
so that happened and then I loved Sports
loved watching sports loved playing
sports
um loved reading the newspaper even when
I was a kid but I was as an unathletic
as they came
and I was always kind of picked last for
different sports things cut from the the
elite sports teams and again and
developing this what's wrong with me
mentality
and as I grew up I started to initially
cope a little bit with food where I
would eat a little bit more of the
unhealthy food than my friends did and I
started to get like a little pudgy when
I was 12 13 years old something like
that 10 11 12 years old I started to get
like a little bit of a belly and I'm
having to wear like now husky pants so
again like but what's wrong with me like
why am I feeling this way why am I
different than my friends like I'm
essentially doing pretty much the same
thing as them
and I'm also setting myself up to be a
victim because I'm like questioning like
why all this is happening to me right
and so when I was 14 I got my first true
chance to escape when my neighbor
offered me a hit off a marijuana pipe
and I remember taking my first hit
and I felt this massive monkey come off
my back like I didn't have to worry if I
was ever going to be good at sports I
didn't have to worry if people would
stop picking on me I didn't have to
worry what my family Dynamics were going
to look like I didn't have to worry what
success because I didn't have to worry
about anything like everything was gone
it was taken from me now mind you like I
never thought in a million years that
when I first started smoking pot that I
would eventually end up in jail and
felony drug charge like nobody does
because if everybody knew that that was
it like a plus b equals c like people
wouldn't start smoking pot if they knew
where the outcome was going to be
and
what I what I found was
I didn't necessarily like being high I
liked the feeling being high gave me I
liked the numbing feeling I liked not
having to worry about anything and that
became very addicting so started to
smoke every day
and started to develop a bit of a habit
and then started to sell a little bit on
the side to make a little bit of money
to support my my pod habit and then on
my um
16th birthday and up until my 16th
birthday there have been a couple other
bad decisions I made when I I had a
party when my mom was in the hospital
um and the cops came busted it ran from
that so that damaged my mom and I's
relationship because the time like I
said they were splitting custody
and then not too long after that on my
16th birthday
I was weighing out a little bit of pot
to sell to my neighbor and my mom walked
in as I was doing it freaked out as you
can imagine again this is like what 20
almost 20 years ago where pot like pot
back then was pretty bad like it was
very stigmatized it wasn't like it is
today where you know a lot of people
were doing it recreationally and legally
and
she could kicked me out she told me I
was forced to go live with my dad
full time which broke my heart because
my dad and I had a horrific relationship
growing up wow that must have been
really difficult it was horrible I mean
I said some things you would never like
a mother would never want to hear from
her son ever and
um
it was a very painful moment for me
because I felt well I think like as
parents like as as a mother like you
kind of have the duty to understand that
like my child's developing and like
might say things they don't mean or in
the Moment In the Heat of something but
ultimately don't really feel to the
deepest parts of their soul but as a
child that's developing like to be
kicked out you know for like a mistake
that you've made and to basically like
be disowned as like I'm not going to be
raising you anymore that must have been
extremely difficult
it was because for a few reasons one
like she knew how difficult my dad was
and because she means she divorced they
divorced like she was married to him
like she knew who he was and then two I
mean I think I mean I guess clearly she
knew and in a way that I was struggling
I was having a hard time I was acting
out consistently I was doing drugs
um you know I wasn't able to kind of
keep up with my end of the bargain as
far as like different job jobs I had at
the time and just even my behavior in
the house
but as I look back like I think she did
the best she could with what she had I
mean I know she was going through a lot
with a divorce she has Ms which I know
is is hard for her as well
so
on top of all that they they thought
you know I think the attentions were
good they thought it would be a good
idea like we're just gonna remove you
from your high school and you're going
to go to the high school that was right
by where my dad lived which was like 30
minutes away and they were like all
right we're going to change his
environment it'll be forced to change
his friends like start over that sort of
thing well now I had all this other pain
trauma insecurities fears coming with me
up until this into this new high school
so what did I do I did whatever I could
to fit in like I was I came in
immediately was like trying to find
friends I could get high with so much so
that people thought I was a cop because
I was like coming up being like hey I
got we I got weed I got weed I got weed
and they're like we really don't know it
was just a very like it was like a funny
situation and
I ended up making new friends continuing
to become even more addicted to pot
barely graduated high school because all
my my friends and I did were was right
around get high listen to music and just
skip class so I almost didn't graduate
because of my poor attendance
and then right after I graduated high
school I decided it was going to be a
good idea to start to actually sell pot
to make like money not just support my
habit
um so so I did I started to do that and
then as you move up the ladder in drug
addiction and drug dealing you begin to
meet people who were doing more drugs
and I met somebody who had some cocaine
and he he I ended up buying a getting or
getting a little bit of cocaine I
remember like
you know starting to snort coke and I
felt this this incredible euphoric
feeling I was like man like this kid who
has no self-esteem no self-confidence
like has no luck with girls like this
substance cannot now makes me feel like
I'm on top of the world
and my addictive uh Behavior caught up
with me with that because I started to
snort that every day developing a habit
with that and the problem with Coke
with a Coke for me was I also had like
really bad anxiety and Coke and anxiety
go about as well together is somebody
trying to lose weight and eating ice
cream and pizza every day like it's just
not a good situation
and I started to get really bad panic
attacks and um into my teenage years and
one of my friends I was like I think I
was like maybe 18 at the time 17 18
something like that 19. offered me a
five milligram percocet
and I took that five milligram percocet
and the same feeling that I got when I
first started the smoke pot was the same
feeling I got when I took that five
milligram percocet and then it was like
Off to the Races from there and this is
what really brought me to my knees like
the five milligrams turned into doing 10
every day 20 40 80 all the way up until
I'm snorting three 400 milligrams every
single day up my nose to support my
habit it was so bad that like half my
left nostril was missing I mean I was
just in a really really
dark place
yeah that is that's intense yeah and
what ended up at the time I thought was
going to be my greatest setback ended up
becoming my my biggest blessing and
here's what happened so I'm 20 years old
Cinco de Mayo 2008
I'm riding around with a few of my
friends to make a drug deal I had a half
a pound of pot in my trunk a couple
thousand dollars in cash in the glove
box and I had a busted headlight that I
had been meaning to fix for for months
that I didn't fix
after you know so many people told me
like Doug you're riding around selling
drugs like you can't ride around the
busted head like what are you doing
so there was a cop running radar because
Cinco de Mayo is like one of the biggest
drinking nights of the year and I guess
it was I guess some sort of sobriety
checkpoint
and I decided it was going to be a
brilliant idea to flash my high beams as
the police officer to hide the fact that
I had a busted headlight
and so what did it do it gave him a
reason to pull me over he said pulls me
over my heart at this point Ellen is in
the pit of my stomach I'm like oh my
gosh my life is over like I knew
everything that I had in the car I just
I just knew things weren't gonna go very
well
pulls me over I stammer to get my my
license and registration out to kind of
give it to the cop and one thing leads
to the next pulls me out
searches the car finds the pot finds the
money and now I'm in handcuffs in the
back of a cop car
facing felony drug charges and I
remember just sitting there Ellen and
like I don't know if anybody's ever
anybody who's listening to this or
watching this has ever like gone through
anything like this where
like all of your bad decisions just
finally catch up with you
and everything as everything as I'm
sitting there just thinking in the back
of the cop kind of came before me and
kind of came to a head where I was like
how did I get here
like how did the kid who just wanted to
be loved how did the kid who just wanted
to be good at sports how did the kid who
just wanted to fit in like how did this
kid end up in the back of this cop car
in handcuffs now facing felony drug
charges and it honestly it came down to
my inability
to cope and manage with stress with the
trauma the pain in my emotions which is
again why I'm so passionate about
sharing what I share now
um
I end up going to jail and I'm charged
with possession felony possession with
intent to distribute marijuana
possession it was possession with intent
distribute marijuana felony drug charge
I mean before you keep going I think
what you said there is so important and
pivotal because it was your sense of
self-worth and not getting to the root
cause of like your feelings and who you
felt as yourself that like kind of LED
you to that just like destructive
Behavior like self-destruction
so how so how do we I I want to hear the
rest of the story for sure but like just
what you just said right there like how
can we get to the root cause and like
help people especially young people who
are maybe going through a ton of
insecurities or bullying
um which is just so common in school and
then add on top of that like trauma at
home like how how do we best help young
people and then even people who are like
adults listening now
that's a great question and it's like
the million dollar question right
because if I had the the magic answer I
think we wouldn't be facing like a lot
of what's going on now I think right for
me from speaking from my own experience
like what really helped me was just
getting
like really clear with
where I went wrong
because there was a lot that went on
that I couldn't control like I couldn't
control my parents getting divorced I
couldn't control kids bullying me I
couldn't control whether a girl said yes
or no to me I couldn't control any of
that
but what I could control
is how I responded to that absolutely
you know and and I I say this because
I made the mistake for years
in blaming everybody else for my
problems but myself
and almost using
the way people treated me as a way to
justify everything else I was doing to
give me a free pass and essentially give
me the green light to behave however I
wanted to just because people were
mistreating me
and what I've learned is that in life
like people are going to mistreat you no
matter what yeah it's just the way it is
but it's how you respond it's how you
respond and you know it's it's tough for
kids because
what I thought would have made me happy
back then
I had later in life and it still didn't
make me happy right yeah it's a very
difficult subject to tackle especially
with like developing brains and young
children and if you don't have that
modeled behavior in your home life that
makes it all the more difficult to
handle like trauma at school right and
you gotta also
and it's tough for kids because they're
not fully developed but you got to
really figure out like what you stand
for or your own identity because what I
learned is that I didn't have my own
identity I was trying to fit in with the
cool kids I was trying to fit in with
the athletes I was trying to fit in with
kids doing drugs I was trying to fit in
here and what happened was other people
started to fill my identity for me and I
didn't know who I was because I was
always yeah does that make sense yeah
and actually that you bring it back to
something that reminds me a lot about my
mom and what she would talk to me about
because I would come home from school
crying often as well because I really
didn't have many friends in elementary
school and was picked on and and I was
just the type of person that I would I
was just very bubbly and outgoing and
just always wanted to be friends with
people so I'd walk up to someone and
boldly say like hey do you want to be my
friend and then when you're in that age
of just insecurities and figuring out
who you are a lot of times that's not
received well and you know trying to be
cool and so I was made fun of and I
would come home crying and my mom would
be like you know what though like that's
them hurting inside and has nothing to
do with you so you go back out there the
next day and you just be yourself Ellen
and that was like the message she
drilled in me every day for my whole
childhood like you be yourself you just
keep being you and don't conform to
other to whatever everyone else is
saying because
most likely they're hurting inside and
that's why they're responding the way
that they are
yeah and that's that's a really good
point and I think for kids sometimes
that's easier like said than done you
know like when you're a teenager you're
like 13 and you're getting bullied all
day at school like when somebody's like
yeah it's just a reflection of who they
are not you the kids like I don't really
care I just want this to stop yeah it
really depends on the severity of it too
like you know of how severe a bullying
you're experiencing so and and each
kid's personality and how they're going
to be able to respond to a message like
that if that's helpful or not yeah for
me it was and I think it's important for
kids to do what they can to kind of
remain strong and not necessarily like
in a way where you have to go bench
press or squat a bunch of weight but
really do what you can to stay active
and it doesn't have to be like I said in
a in a way where you're going to the gym
all the time but you know even trying to
keep up with whatever
Athletics that you're able to do walking
just just hanging out and hanging out
with friends in the neighborhood and
just if somebody doesn't treat you right
like don't try to convince them to like
you right like find your tribe and just
also know that like the quickest way to
get a bully to stop is just to stop
engaging you see that I look at like
online like you think about somebody
who's just constantly commenting
negative stuff on your post and then you
engage with them like what happens they
keep commenting but the moment you stop
like you don't it's like crickets you
don't hear from them again and it's kind
of the same thing with like I think with
kids
in school like one of the ways I mean
there's obviously many ways to deal with
this but one of the ways is just not to
feed into the the their fire and feed
into the attention that they're seeking
right I think the other thing too is
to just just don't be afraid to ask for
help and just know that you're not alone
I mean I know it's really really hard
for kids these days because they feel
like weak they feel ashamed they feel
um you know almost like last them when
they have to ask for help but it takes a
it takes a really strong person
to ask for help yeah Shifting the the
mindset on what asking for help really
means is really interesting and powerful
and then on top of it what you're saying
about kids now there's social media like
young kids are on social media as adults
it's hard to deal with like massive
criticism criticism and then take that
with like a young child who is dealing
with it maybe in person but also online
like just exponentially adds to it I
think it's really hard sometimes for me
to relate
to to certain things now
the kids struggle with with specifically
social media because I didn't grow up in
a world of social media I mean I think I
Facebook I think came out when I was
like a I I don't remember if it was I
was a junior in high school senior or I
just graduated it was like somewhere in
that time frame
I mean but before that it was like my
space and then like AOL meant it's
instant messenger and like that was oh
yeah that's how my husband and I started
talking it was AOL instant messaging
there we go we were we were on we went
to the same high school but we wouldn't
talk in person it was when like we were
just too nervous to talk in person but
we would talk on AOL instead messaging
no one had like smartphones weren't a
thing back then either for us yeah and
if and if you're a parent like listening
to this and you have a kid that's kind
of struggling I mean all I can say based
on like a lot of the experts I've talked
to is there's a few things one like
modeling is so important
like I've learned just from interviewing
different people or talking to different
people that like your kids will pick up
on the way that you manage your own
emotions so if a kid is watching you not
be able to regulate yourself or manage
your own stress
that kid is going to essentially like
like learn that that's how you deal with
stress is you deal with it by you know
freaking out and losing your cool all
the time and you know drinking and doing
all these things and that kid's going to
see that as normal instead of like I
think being able to somehow model
like some healthy coping mechanisms and
healthy conflict and not shying it away
either like because I think that's also
bad where if you just teach your kids
there's never going to be any conflict I
mean that's not true there's going to be
conflict
um absolutely everything you just said
for sure yeah and then the other the
other thing too is just making sure that
you as parents you know that again this
sounds cliche but you're not alone
because and I say this because there's a
lot of parents and a lot of parents who
talk to me when they come to me they
think they're alone they think like why
is this happening to me like I feel like
I'm the only one like I don't have
anybody to talk to
um what are people going to think of me
when I tell them
and the fact of the matter is
there's so many people that are going
through it especially right now with
kids that are struggling so try to find
some sort of support group whether
that's through something like Al-Anon or
I mean there's plenty of resources even
online to connect with other parents who
are going through kit with going through
something where kids are struggling and
then also I cannot emphasize this enough
is taking care of yourself
because
um we're in this we're in this world
right now where I see it where parents
are almost like taking care of their
kids like a hundred percent of the time
and not doing anything for themselves
now again I'm not a parent I'm not it's
you know it might be hard for people to
listen to this book well he's not a
parent he doesn't get it you're right I
mean there's certain things I don't get
right now but what I do know
is that if you don't take care of
yourself at all and you're sacrificing
your sleep all of your money your health
your Wellness like everything for your
kids
like you're number one gonna be a mess
number two you're gonna teach your kids
to be a people pleaser the rest of their
lives you're going to teach your kids to
be codependent you're going to teach
your kids to not value their own health
and wellness as they grow up and is that
really what you want
absolutely I don't think you have to be
a parent to be able to say that message
because it's true well it is it is more
difficult to take care of yourself
because you're taking care of other
people you know other little people in
the world who need a lot from you you
have to show that that you have to have
boundaries essentially to show that like
I want to help you I'm going to help you
but I also need to do this and this is a
time where I'm taking care of myself and
that's a really good thing for model to
model for kids where are you showing you
taking care of yourself and valuing your
Wellness
yeah and and it also like I think
something else that's really important
for people to to hear is that not
everybody's gonna like you like and
that's a hard thing for to accept and
yeah
um you know take on sometimes because
all we want is humans is to is to be
loved for who we are and be accepted
right be seen be heard all those things
there's just going to be certain people
that you just don't jive with there's
going to be certain people you just
can't be around because they're just
constantly negative or they're picking
on you or whatever and that's okay like
you just kind of have to just move on
and accept that that person like isn't
meant to be in your life at that time
yeah absolutely and that's for not only
just for kids but in to adulthood as
well a lot of people if they aren't
learning while they're young that look
it's okay if not everybody likes you and
the importance of like integrity and in
yourself then they have us they struggle
with that into their adult relationships
as well and it's a really good reminder
that that even is a struggle for people
for people's criticisms online that
you'll never meet in your life you'll
never even seen their face it's just a
random comment you don't even know who
this person is or what their life is
like and you're and it's easy to let
that one sentence or comment get and
affect your sense of self-worth and how
how interesting is that like you'll
never see that person you don't even
know who that person is and yet for some
people or a lot of people that can
affect your own sense of self and how
you feel and so that's why working on
yourself and in your ability to be
confident that not everybody's gonna
like you and that's okay that doesn't
mean you you don't accept like
constructive
criticism or constructive thoughts it
doesn't mean that at all it's it's
really there's a difference between like
just outright this person doesn't like
you
and I think there's there's something
there too where I heard um I think I
think it was good Joe Rogan said
something like he's like you never see
like Michael Jordan leaving negative uh
YouTube comments
and I guess the the take-home message I
think for that is that like you don't
see people who are happy with themselves
seeing success or looking to better the
world like they don't have the time or
the energy to like sit there and just
comment on something negative right well
absolutely yeah that actually there's a
message sorry to interrupt there but
there's a there's something that a
YouTuber had said a while ago I think
her YouTube channel is called Superwoman
something I forget but she's really cool
and she made a video about you know like
negative comments and stuff and she said
that you're never you'll never be
criticized by someone who's doing more
than you because that person doesn't
have time to criticize you they're
focusing on their own growth and what
they can do what they're working on to
better the world or better themselves or
whatever help people around them as
opposed to taking time to criticize or
put down others right and I think
sometimes we feed more into the negative
stuff because our brain is like kind of
wired for survival so if we see
something negative it's like oh my gosh
like am I in danger okay have to fix
something like what can I do to change
this instead of just kind of accepting
that all right like it's okay like if
you're on social media and you're
posting stuff there's a chance that
you're going to get some hate there's
going to be somebody who doesn't agree
with you there's going to be something
that you say during a time of
um during a time when emotions are
heightened that you know might offend
somebody that's okay like but I think
what happens Ellen is that people
take the opposite approach and like you
know what I'm just not even going to
post anything anymore I'm not even going
to share my opinion or I'm going to
actually not even not gonna share my
opinion I'm going to change my opinion
uh even if it's something I don't
believe in just so I fit in and then
what happens then you start to lose your
identity which is exactly like what I
did Growing Up like as we kind of like
get back to like what I was saying is
that
I
knew that what I was doing was not right
like I knew
in my mind that I shouldn't have been
like manipulating people to get money
for drugs I knew in my mind that I had
so much more potential to achieve
certain things the problem was there was
this disconnect between like my my
knowledge of that and then the how to
implement it into action and develop
self-confidence to be able to actually
take these steps to get there because
I'm caught up I was I was caught up and
I think so many other people are caught
up in these
crazy
gigantic
inflated goals from the start instead of
like thinking about what you need to do
on a daily basis and if you can seem
intimidating for me like my thoughts
were gosh I need to stop doing drugs I
can never use drugs again instead of
like why not just not do drugs tomorrow
why not just not do drugs for a week
like why think of it in terms of like
forever
or I I was 50 pounds heavier than I am
now my goal was always I need to like
lose all this weight instead of like I
just need to I need to lose like two
pounds three pounds because it becomes
so overwhelming for people when they're
like gosh like I haven't been able to
to lose like you know five pounds my
whole life like why would I be able to
lose a hundred pounds
and yeah
and so this this is the reason this is
important to me is this is that jail
saved my life and I think this is kind
of an important maybe
a good segue into like finish yeah yeah
let's get back into your story yeah and
so I got arrested and then was charged
with the felony drug charges a few
months later September of 2008 September
30th 2008 I go to court
and the judge in my mind kind of threw
the book at me he convicted me of the
felony
he sentenced me to five years in jail
but suspended everything but 90 days
meaning if I failed a drug test if I
missed a probation appointment if I
didn't do my community service that he
would end up giving me if I did anything
wrong that violated those terms I could
potentially go back and serve the full
five years
he gave me five years probation 200
hours community service all kinds of
fines and drug classes but he looked me
dead in the eye and he said Doug you're
young you are
um you're 20 years old
he said this felony conviction is going
to haunt you the rest of your life
he was like so I'm willing to give you a
break and I'm like break after what you
just told me like where's where's the
break like I'm going to freaking jail
he's like if you complete everything
without messing up
you do your community service you do
your time in jail you do your probation
you you know you stay on a straightened
path he's like at the end of your five
years of probation
you can come back to court and I will
take the felony conviction off your
record and give you PBJ preparation
before judgment so then then no long I
would no longer be a convicted felon
and at the time of course I'm like I'm
high in court I'm gonna get high when I
leave I'm like it's like 2008 I'm like
isn't the world supposed to end in 2012
like you know I didn't think I was gonna
live to see my 25th birthday so I was
like whatever like I'll take the deal
like whatever you got it
and
I reported a jail
about a week after my 21st birthday
October 21st 2008 is when I reported the
jail
and as anybody who's listening or
watching this based on what I just told
you were my self-confidence and my
athletic ability and self-esteem was I
was scared of every like thing every
fear anybody has about jail was going
through my mind like non-stop like of
what was gonna happen to me
and then on top of all the fear anger
sadness emotions I had this horrific
opiate uh Habit to kick and detox so
when I got to the Detention Center I
literally
cried because I didn't want to go in but
the crazy thing is this when I the day I
got out I cried because I didn't want to
leave
and when I got there the first thing
like I said I had to do was deal with
this opiate detox which
felt like having the worst case of the
flu for like weeks and some of the
symptoms were like uncontrollable
vomiting uncontrollable bowel movements
shakes pain anxiety depression sleepless
nights like everything nausea
but the symptom that I thought was the
hardest for me back then but ironically
I think it's the most important was this
feeling of I felt like I was trying to
crawl out of my own skin
like it was weird like I felt I
literally felt like like a part of me
was gonna leave
Doug's body it was very strange
as I look back
I believe that it was like the old me
trying to leave so that the new me can
become whole
and my soon-to-be cellmate
was sitting at the Scrabble table
and he looked at me and he could just
tell my shoulders were rounded forward I
talked very quietly I didn't I was very
quiet I was um I didn't say many words
um I just looked terrified people
thought I was a zombie when I was in
there because I was so out of it but he
said
you're going to start working out with
me when you get through your detox and I
was just like huh like there's no way
I'm like have you seen me I'm like I
could have been a model for Pillsbury at
the time and I was like nah man I'm good
he's like all right man
so not too long after that I see him
work out he was like a more he looked
like a more jacked version of Brad Pitt
from Fight Club
and I saw I saw him work out and he was
doing like thousands of push-ups
hundreds of pull-ups like running all
over this common area and I was like
like who is this guy I've been a
personal trainer now for
like about 11 over well over 11 years
now and he's the most one of the most
fit people I've ever seen in person to
this day
yeah so he was he was there for years
um for like a bunch of different
felonies I think his thing was he was he
was a drug addict too and I think he
would go and burglarize homes
and then I guess sell either sell the
stuff or somehow to get money to buy
drugs and he had all these felonies on
his record and he was I believe I think
he was in prison
in pencil and Pennsylvania before he was
in Maryland with me and then just by the
grace of God like literally like
literally by the grace of God he had
like I think violated his parole or
something in Maryland to where he had to
come back to to that County I was in
um while he was awaiting trial for his
violation I think it was something like
that like it was just crazy how he was
there
and um he since he passed away a few
months and I actually had the um the
great Fortune of speaking at his funeral
his family had reached out to me after
he passed away because he talked about
me a lot and how much of an impact he
had in my own transformation that they
they knew
um that I would want to I would want to
know him that he would want me to kind
of be there
so
not too long after I saw him work out
we're in the cell and this conversation
can I cuss on here
yeah okay yeah and I think this is I
think again this is this is a this
conversation changed my life
and I remember just sitting there
talking to him and he's like asking me
more about my story he's like like what
brought you here like why did you get so
addicted to drugs he's just asking me
different things
and I started blaming everybody I
started to say well my parents got
divorced or girls rejected me I was
bullied all these things again like I
was blaming the things I couldn't
control
for the actions that I took
and he looked at me he was just like
quit being a [ __ ]
and I was just like huh
would you say to me excuse me I was like
uh because I mean you you never want to
be called that let alone like you don't
want it's not something you want to be
called like when you're in jail right
let alone anywhere yeah yeah and if
you're kind of pouring out like what
you're struggling with you you're
looking for like you're hoping for maybe
comfort and like agreeance like oh yeah
that makes sense right and and I guess
like
at that time
I was looking for
like a conversation where I got told
what I wanted to hear
but he told me what he needed to hear
and what he proceeded to say he told me
what I needed to hear what he proceeded
to tell me was he's like Doug look
there's plenty of people that went
through what you went through that
aren't in jail right now right and I was
like yup
he was like you have two choices he's
like you'd be a man look yourself in the
mirror and say that you chose to get
yourself here you made those decisions
and it's on you to get yourself out of
this no one's coming to save you like no
that's the thing like we live in this
world where people are waiting for like
you know different people in their lives
or waiting for like uh like the
government they're waiting for people to
come in and just save them and that the
hard truth is no one's coming like no
one like I'm a Christian and I believe
obviously Jesus can save you from from
things but take the spirituality aspect
out of what I'm saying on this earth
like no one is coming to save you
and it's on you that if you're in the
thick of it if you're in a a place where
you're really struggling like you have
to change
the choices that you are making and I
don't care how small they are I don't
care how tiny they are things have to
change like what's the old saying it's
like nothing changes if nothing changes
right
and
when he said when he said those words to
me
I could just say kind of a my my brain
was completely kind of shut off from
everything I was going through but a
little spark like started to light up in
there and was like man I think he's
right like you know up until that point
I thought I had everything figured out
he was like
um
I I thought that I knew it all and I was
like man maybe maybe I don't I mean I
had 21 jobs at the time I was 21 I would
damage all these relationships I was a
drug addict I'm in jail for felony drug
charges I was hopeless I was all these
things like clearly I don't have it all
figured out
and so he said you can be a man or you
can be a [ __ ] he was like you could be
a [ __ ] you could cry in the corner say
woe is me blame everybody else for your
problems wait for you know people to
come save you like like you can go do
that like no one he's like most people
will do that he's like so those are your
two choices
and for the first time I felt like
invigorated like I felt like wow like I
think that I can actually maybe try and
change my life
and I mean it's so true what you said
about how sometimes what you need to
hear isn't what you want to hear a lot
of times it's when you're kind of
hitting rock bottom or you're in like
the lowest to the lowest place and you
think you think you know what you want
to hear or what you think you need to
hear but what you actually need to hear
is something that in the moment might be
really hard but it's actually what
changes you changes your mindset and
transforms you I mean I have that
experience even like within birth like a
midwife just snapping me out of it I
know that you haven't
um experienced that but there's
something about it that like in it it's
I was you know in a really low place at
one point in my first birth and it
wasn't until my Midwife came and snapped
me out of it and just said something
that just I didn't want to hear but I
needed to hear and then that's what
transformed me and made the rest of my
birth so much better so just relating to
that that happens so much in life where
what you need to hear is in always what
you want to hear
right and I think I don't want to
like underlie the fact that the people
do go through some really hard things
and people are are dealt some really
heavy circumstances that are are painful
to deal with and I can't even imagine
right how hard it is based on what
certain people have told me with with
their stories
but absolutely just speaking from my own
experience and the experience of
countless others that I've had
conversations with about
turning a negative into a positive
making the most out of moments of
adversity
like the thing that that helped them
was them
was deciding to change who they were and
deciding to change the course of their
life like not one person was like yeah
like the government just swooped in they
like gave me all this money and boom
like I was rich yeah you know this
random guy just came and gave me
everything and that's how my life is so
much better right and I think when we've
experienced hardship growing up or we've
even dealt a bad hand we we developed
this mindset where we feel like we're
owed all this stuff because we we like
kind of fell behind early on so we're
like oh like I'm old with all this stuff
so bet people better like give me things
because of how hard I had it
but I quickly hopefully we hopefully you
quickly realize it's just not the way
the world works and yeah I would think I
feel like it's helpful to even say that
like it doesn't mean that you're
necessarily saying No One's Gonna help
anyone else just fend for yourself it's
more the mindset of like maybe don't
assume that that's the the way for you
to become successful in whatever form
success looks like for you because you
know it's like so many people help
others and that's like such a beautiful
thing that we should all be encouraging
as a society as people to be helping
others in need but like when it comes to
your own struggles instead of like
assuming or saying that like I can only
get to point B if this is handed to me
that that's the damaging mindset yeah
exactly I mean that's just it again I
think I had some help along the way I
mean I went and lived with my
grandparents when I got out of jail and
they kind of they helped me out with
food you know letting me like live there
rent free and that sort of thing but I
also had to do my part like I had to you
know work on getting a job I had to
exercise I had to keep my that my room
and stuff clean I had to respect them
and their rules I had to you know stay
clean all those things like I had to do
my part and what you said is exactly
what I what I'm saying it's not that no
one's gonna ever help you with anything
it's that you have to almost assume that
no one is and you have to almost like
pretend that and I think when you do
that you focus on what you can control
and you really own that you have this
um this level of self-awareness that's
unbreakable as far as like what you know
you need to do on a daily basis to
become a better version of yourself
like people kind of show up and they
kind of help you along the way but if
you if you would absolutely if you adopt
the mindset that it's automatically
going to happen because you're owed it
that's what that's where I mean I think
that people will end up um kind of
falling short and
after this conversation
I decided to give exercise a try in jail
and
I got down to do a push-up
couldn't do a push-up could barely do
one for my knees
and I was mortified I was embarrassed
because I could also barely walk up and
down the steps in there because I was
you know smoking on like a pack pack and
a half of cigarettes a day
and
um my cellmate agreed to train me in
there every single day during my 90-day
sentence and we set some goals to to
like run a mile and do a set of 10
push-ups for the time I left jail and
with his motivation encouragement
holding me accountable like literally
like
being this amazing coach to me while I
was there I was able to do it I was able
to run that mile I was able to do that
set of push-ups
and it changed my life and it's not the
push-ups and everything else like
physically necessarily that like led me
to having this mindset it's what they
did for me it got me finally for the
first time being comfortable being
uncomfortable I was terrified of what
other people thought of me for the
longest time in my life and now I'm in
front of a bunch of grown men
getting down on the floor and can barely
do a push-up from my knees like how
embarrassing is that but I learned that
nobody cares like nobody they might look
at you and they might kind of giggle at
first but then once they see you keep
showing up keep showing up and getting
better and getting better it's like
almost they become like your
cheerleaders not necessarily the people
that are saying stuff to you because
they're like wow like either this guy is
really dedicated and good for him or or
I wish I was doing it so maybe I'm gonna
Inspire I'm gonna get inspired to do
this and then you just learn that you
adopt this mentality that
like the things that you think people
care about are the things that people
don't care about as far as like what
you're doing right and
and so I also developed self-discipline
which I never had I was finally able to
stick to something and be able to like
follow through with the things I said I
was going to do for myself and that I
think is the biggest way to develop
self-confidence is to essentially like
just keep your word
like show up for yourself and there was
no better way to show myself love than
to invest it into my health and fitness
and then the other thing too was I
started to like walk a certain way I
started to walk a different way my
shoulders were now like back a little
bit my head was up I started to tell
myself that I could do things instead of
that I couldn't I started to tell myself
that I was worthy of changing instead of
that I couldn't I started telling myself
that I was going to have success even
though like up until that point I told
myself that I was going to be a failure
the rest of my life and the other thing
is it it taught me the importance of
playing the long game
I remember having a conversation
conversation with my cell mate one night
and I was like how long is it going to
take me to like lose all this weight
he was like well how long have you been
beating your body up like a long time
he's like well it's gonna take a long
time Doug and so I began to learn that
like things didn't happen overnight
and so I had this massive Spiritual
Awakening I had this this Angel come in
and really help me during my time in
there and then I had this massive shift
physically mentally emotionally and
spiritually to where the day I got out
I asked my cell mate like how I was ever
going to repay him
and he said don't mess up and pay it
forward and he gave me a workout routine
that I still have framed in my place
today so I never forget where I came
from
got out stayed on the the workout
program
um lost a bunch of weight and then got
to a place in my got to a place Fitness
wise where I wanted to help other people
use Fitness to change their lives and
became a trainer back in April of 2011
and was very blessed to be able to build
a really successful personal training
business because I
found this new high and found this new
meaning in helping people use Health
wellness fitness inspiration to change
their lives and kind of you know time
flew by and my probation was up
um in September of
2000 and uh or like yeah later on in the
year in 2013
because I couldn't remember if it was
over when I went to court or after I got
out of jail but my the probation was
over towards the end of 2013 and one of
my clients just happened to be a lawyer
and we wrote the judge uh for to grant
me like a modification for my sentence
and the judge got got back and granted
me my day in court and so in January of
2014 he took the felony conviction off
my record and gave me that PBJ because I
fulfilled my end of the bargain I didn't
touch drugs I completed my probation my
community service like everything I
restitution or paid all my fines and
everything else
and I never realized how much
one's life can change from being like
Shackled you know as a convicted fellow
and not being able to do certain things
and not being a free man and that
inspired me to to write my first book
from Felony to Fitness to free to
inspire people to make the most of their
second chance turn it to give turn a
negative into a positive and focus on
how far they've come and not how far
they have to go and you know ever since
then I've just been on an absolute
mission to to share my story to help
other people use adversity to their
advantage and just to give people hope
and written a couple other books we've
been voted a fitness Hero by The
Baltimore Sun here I've been able to
share my story on some pretty amazing
podcasts and media outlets and and now
I'm here kind of talking to you and and
I just I just want people to know that
like I never thought that I would be
here like where I'm at right now
like and I never I never thought that I
think a lot of times we get caught up in
like future tripping and being like man
like how am I gonna make it in two years
how am I gonna make it in three years or
what am I gonna do and the reality is
like things change
and you just have to take it day by day
week by week and just take small steps
and keep celebrating those small wins
right because that's what happened for
me like for me it was like I couldn't do
a push-up then I could do a push-up what
was next oh I'm gonna do two push-ups oh
what's next three push-ups and I was
able to do 10 push-ups then what's next
I'm gonna do a set of 20. and then with
like running I couldn't even like barely
walk up and down the steps but now I
could like run a quarter mile then a
half a mile then a mile then I'm running
a 5k and then it's like oh like maybe
I'm gonna become a trainer now like now
I have all this confidence I never have
and become a trainer I'm gonna help
other people that gave me some like a
new level of confidence then I was like
I'm gonna write a book even though at
the time like I barely graduated high
school but now I had this this level of
self-confidence and self-esteem they
knew that to know that I was worthy so
I'm gonna write this book and you can
see where I'm going with this where you
just eventually just start stacking
things one on top of each other and then
you look back and you're like how did I
get here and it wasn't because I had
some big aha moment decided to do all
this at once like I said at the
beginning of our conversation it was
like just these small wins day by day
focusing on how far I've come and just
just celebrating things as they go
yeah and it and it really comes down to
coming from a place of living in
victimhood mentality versus a Victor
mentality and I always like to talk
about this in a way that like you
there's a difference between being a
victim to something versus living in a
victimhood mentality and something
shifted within you based on that Mentor
essentially who was in prison for you
like in prison with you and to me this
also makes me think of something I'd
love to get your thoughts on is the idea
you mentioned a little bit about
surrounding yourself with people who are
going to uplift you encourage you
um and and be a good source of light for
you in your in your world and I totally
agree but I recently also heard
something that was an interesting
um kind of way to balance that thought
process because it's a that's a very
popular thing that's getting talked on
not the way you said it but something
that's you know very common on social
media right now is like cut toxic people
out of your life and you know for your
own mental health and everything's about
like for yourself right but really that
that man in prison like he took the time
to help you when if he had taken that
message that's like all of her social
media right now like keep the toxic
people out of your life like he would
have never helped you or planted that
seed in you that really changed your
life and so I thought that was an
interesting thing that I've heard
basically kind of pushing back on that
notion as like we would never say that
for anything else in life like rich
people don't help poor people like like
that would never be a slogan right like
it's always like encouraged for people
who have something to be able to to
share it and help others and so so I
feel like there's a balance there
between realizing the benefit and
helping others and being there for
people not being so quick to cut out
toxic people of your life right like
this is slightly different to what
you're saying but I just think it's an
interesting topic based on when I look
at your story and that person who was in
jail with you that completely helped you
shift your mindset from victimhood
mentality to Victor mentality what are
your thoughts I I agree with you and I
was having a conversation like this with
somebody the other day we were talking
about like social media and there's
another popular idea where it's like you
should just unfollow people that like
trigger you right and it's like okay
like I think there's room for that like
I think that like the bulk of the people
you spend time with the bulk of your
like energy you should be spending it
with people that are like go get I mean
if you're if you're a go-getter like and
you want to you want to be surrounding
yourself for the most part with other
go-getters people that are going to
elevate you people that are going to
challenge you and maybe you're not doing
something right or somebody that can
like kind of kind of help guide you
along the way like I totally see that
but
I think being of service is is crucial
and that's been something that's been a
staple of my life over yeah um like the
last you know
13 14 years or how you know however long
it's been
and probably partly because you saw
somebody helping you and how much it
changed your life and so you're like I
want to go do the same oh yeah he said I
said how can I repay you he told me to
pay it forward and back then I never
read a personal development book I
didn't I didn't know what that really
meant but I was just like all right man
but then like I started to understand
what it meant I was like man this is
crazy like I love helping people with
Fitness and that that was a big thing
for me and with my cellmate
like that's kind of what he saw on me
now if I had been like
constantly every single day like you
know emotionally like attacking him and
stuff like that then like I don't think
he would have helped me because there
was times where I pushed back and he was
just like dude like if you don't want to
be helped then bye totally yeah there's
about there's a balance in any of that
because for somebody who's like has
somebody in their life that's extremely
damaging and it's over and over and over
again and you're trying to either help
or be there for them or whatever like or
if someone you know is abusing you right
like in a relationship like of course
like you have to cut certain ties and
cut people out of your life absolutely
it's more just the balance of this idea
that's taken hold on social media that's
like anytime someone does something you
don't like or if they're like you know
making you uncomfortable basically
essentially cut them out of your life
well I think that's that's a problem
right I think when yeah you just assume
that somebody if you have The Stance
that you assume that somebody doesn't
agree with you is like dangerous to you
yeah yeah that's super popular now
you're gonna carry on this mindset that
when somebody doesn't agree with you
that you should just not spend any time
with them where like
a lot of the people I spend time with
like we might have a lot of common
commonalities as far as like maybe like
podcasting or you know like liking the
podcast personal development
um fitness health Wellness like that
sort of thing but like ours our views on
society are different like I see the
world one way somebody else might see it
and then we were able to have like these
conversations where because I mean
that's the way to develop empathy right
and to be able to like see somebody
else's side is to like absolutely have a
conversation and listen and I think the
the idea the intent
of the
um like kind of shielding yourself from
the toxicity of certain things
is is good the impact I think can be
indirectly negative because now like I
said I said you're teaching yourself
that people don't agree with you or can
potentially be dangerous but also that
you you shouldn't like look in the
freaking mirror and try to understand
like why this is bothering you so much
like why like for me like just an
example if I saw
um a guy posting a picture with his wife
and two kids and every time I saw that I
would go into my room and cry and I
would just be like you know what I'm not
gonna all anybody who I know who's
married with kids any guy that is a
friend of mine that I follow like I'm
unfollowing you because it's too painful
instead of me being like oh wait a
minute like why is this painful for me
like why is this bothering me so much
because then again it just goes back to
like the theme of the conversation
you're blaming everybody else for your
problems you're blaming everybody else
for your emotions you're blaming
everybody else for the way that you feel
about yourself and you're not taking any
time to look in the mirror because
and that's the easy thing to do right is
to just bypass all of that and I think
in this in the world where
um we're people now on social media it's
like it's like the big thing to protect
your mental health and everybody should
be loved for who they are and everybody
needs to be seen and I'm for that like
you're I'm here talking about my mental
health struggles I'm here talking about
the importance of taking care of
yourself I'm for that
but now people I think have taken it to
an extreme
where
they're they're just trying to they're
almost like bypassing like the the
obvious they're bypassing the common the
name common denominator and looking for
things to blame other than themselves
it's it's social media it's that person
it's this person it's this job and now
I'm just gonna cut cut and then sure
enough all you have is yourself and
you're just by yourself you think you
know everything you Shield yourself from
certain things and you never like get to
the point where
you you reach this this level of Peace
inside of yourself because you've taken
the time to look at yourself in the
mirror and say man like
this is hard a lot of this that I'm
seeing is really painful for me
and I'm also acknowledging like why
and that's the difference
yeah so what are your thoughts on the
idea that you know pulling yourself up
by your bootstraps
mentality or thought process or message
is a privileged way to think and that
some people are going through such hard
circumstances which you mentioned and
acknowledged because of course some
people are going through such extremely
difficult circumstances that maybe is it
possible that a message like that would
be too difficult to hear or like what
are your just thoughts on that General
notion
I mean I definitely think that again I
think I said this I think people are
dealt circumstances that were much much
more challenging than me I think
everybody's situation is different I can
only speak for my own personal
experience
I do think that societally I do think we
need some change I definitely think we
need some prison reform I think like
throwing drug addicts in jail it just
doesn't it's not the solution like at
all right yeah we talked about I talked
about that on an episode with um Dominic
Thompson I don't know if you know who he
is but he's a friend of mine and we did
a whole a whole episode on like prison
system issues and
um his experience in prison as well and
it was a really great episode I
encourage anyone listening go check it
out
I mean it's it's I'm glad you did that
because it's so true and it's so needed
right in that
like I just think that things need to
change you know people they're not
getting the hey they're not getting the
proper Rehabilitation I don't I don't
think when they're behind bars for a
long time when clearly like
you know for almost all I would say
people that are
addicted to drugs like there's something
going on inside that's that's hurting
it's painful like I think addiction is
an internal battle that's often
displayed externally so I think that
to something that needs to change and I
think also like
you know I said that no one's coming to
save you and I do I do believe that like
I do think that having that mentality is
important not because I think it's
always true like I said I think you can
have some help along the way I got some
help along the way with my grandparents
my cell mate and other things I think
the reason I think it's so important
is because when you relinquish control
and power onto somebody else you lose
because now you're putting all your
hopes into things you can't control and
it's in the stuff that you're really
powerless over and you're essentially
just giving away any responsibility or
accountability and you then you feel
like the world is against you and owes
you things and I think you'll start to
behave in that way and
I think
just really getting good at mastering
these mental prisons that we live in
when we are in dark times is the way to
win the dark prisons of
impulsiveness and wanting to numb the
pain instantly or acting out in ways
that aren't conducive with who we want
to be
hanging out with
people that don't bring the best out on
us I mean the people that are like you
know damaging us emotionally and
mentally
or
um you know feeling sorry for yourself
being a victim and the reason that I say
that is because
like thinking that way doesn't make the
situation any better what can make the
situation better at least give you a
chance
is is taking small steps and making
different choices
yeah and then something I'd want to add
to that too on top of what you said I
love what you said is that anyone
listening who has the ability to help
someone else who is going through
something very difficult extreme having
like like you'd mentioned some people
who have had there are many people have
had even more extreme situations and
circumstances growing up of childhood
abuse or spousal abuse or
um just Financial extreme Financial
struggles like anyone who is listening
if you have the ability to help to do
that and so it's kind of like a two-way
fold where like encouraging the people
who can help to do that as well as
encouraging a victim mindset and I feel
like together
um that helps somebody should have one
try to get on your podcast is I had on
um Dr Edith eager are you familiar with
her she's like a 90 I think she might be
94 now but she at the time she was a 93
year old Holocaust Survivor like she
survived Auschwitz like both of her
parents right were killed like shortly
after her getting there and I remember
having a conversation like this with her
where we were talking about like like
how do you how do you manage something
like that when you're in the thick of it
and she
said something similar where it was her
ability to like really Master her mind
that they couldn't take her mind away
from her was what saved her life
that was like the one thing they
couldn't take yeah and
you know now I think she's a clinical
psychologist I believe and has written a
couple books and
um what was her name again I'm gonna
have to look into her Edith eager I'll
I'll text you uh her info and I can help
try to get you connected but yeah I mean
that was like some of the I think I
believed I mean
don't don't quote me on this but I
believe I think it was somebody in her
family it might have been her mom or
somebody told her that they they
couldn't take her mind from her or
something like it was something to that
effect and
that's how she survived
right and like and I think the message
here is that like when you're in these
situations like for again for me like
when I was in jail if I decided to act
violently I would have gotten the crap
beaten out of me right you know I would
have probably had every bone in my body
broken and
I would have been put potentially in
solitary confinement got a new charge
gotten new charges and I would have been
in prison for a lot longer like how
would that have how would that have
served me right that wouldn't have
helped
and that's that's the lesson right is
that
situations circumstances they freaking
suck
hard man like it's so hard to go through
some of these things that people go
through
but what I think is also hard
is is looking back
like three five ten years later and
being like man I wish I would have
responded differently
yeah and that goes for even smaller big
situations that the way that you respond
to something in your mindset it plays a
huge role in the outcome
totally
and I think we
we can't control like there's a lot we
can't control in life we can't control
what happens tomorrow we can't control
what happens the next day but
there's a lot we we do can have control
over we have control over
how we choose to spend our time for the
most part
we we have control over whether we're
going to get some sort of movement and
for the day doesn't have to be hours at
the gym could be a five minute walk
could be a hike in nature whatever
for the most part we have autonomy and
how who we're going to spend time with
and we've touched on this but
I I think nutrition isn't just what you
eat it's like who you like what you're
watching on TV it's what you're
listening to it's what you're reading
um it's it's who you're spending time
with and you don't have to completely
Shield yourself from things that are
negative or or trigger you but
I think like limiting that to the best
of your ability and just using it as a
way to gain some level of self-awareness
about yourself and stay informed
I think is important
and like personal development personal
growth to be able to handle like going
back to what you said that when someone
is sharing something that you disagree
with if it's triggering to you asking
yourself why and working on yourself to
not be so triggered and be more open to
just listen
right and don't feel like you have to
always say something I think that's like
the yeah the world now is like everybody
feels like they have to chime in and say
something when and maybe they're not
even like like they don't really know
what they're talking about in some ways
but they're just saying it's just a fit
in right and I'm not I'm not saying you
shouldn't speak out on something you're
passionate about there's nothing to do
with that but it goes back to this
level of not knowing who you are not
knowing what your identity is in that
like you just see someone talking about
something and then you automatically
feel that you should say something
because you want to fit in and you might
not have any like idea of like what's
going on and sometimes people like they
almost like regret saying something
because they almost like man like I
don't know why I said that like I was
completely I was completely wrong or I
yeah I am not a fan of that at all when
I see something blowing up on social
media that every influencer chimes in is
like well I gotta say it too just so
people don't think I'm this X Y or Z as
opposed to like is that you know what
exactly are you really feeling is that
what's your motive and your reason
behind what you're sharing and is it
because you're feeling pressure and as
opposed to being authentic to who you
are like yeah I'm not a fan of that at
all
yeah I mean I try and I just stay if I
don't know something I stay out of it I
try to
keep myself informed on like all views
because
it's easy to get caught up in these Echo
Chambers
yeah and again that's the point of the
problem when you only follow certain
people on social media or you only spend
time with certain people is that you end
up you end up getting like shielded from
like what the reality of what the other
half of the world looks like because
you're so narrow-minded and you're in
this you have like tunnel vision because
you only see
like what with what's in front of you in
the way of the opinions and the the
accounts you follow on social media and
a lot of it it just reinforces like what
you think you already believe
and then it yeah and something I say a
lot to people is
um if you're saying I how could someone
think X Y or Z I could never understand
I can't even believe that someone would
think this like that's not something to
be proud of to not understand why the
person who disagrees with you thinks the
way that they do it's it's actually not
very admirable it's much more admirable
to be able to say hey I understand how
you got there I at least get like why
you think that I disagree but and here's
why but to just be like I can't even
believe that just shows your own your
own self Echo chamber that you're living
in that you can't understand why someone
got there or why someone thinks the way
that they do
right and I think I also encourage
people to like go spend time like in
that place and learn more right like
learn more about the culture of whatever
it is like you know I've I've been
fortunate enough to volunteer like in in
the county jails here locally or in the
county excuse me in the local County
Jail jail here I'm fortunate to
volunteer and like homeless shelters and
stuff like that and you learn to
understand like what people go through
that are less fortunate than you
and um that's how you develop empathy
you know and compassion and and really
again and also gaining understanding of
like like what might work to change
things because you begin to actually
talk to the to the people or talk to
people you go into the environments of
where things are are not maybe not good
or not ideal
and then you like get to see it with
your own two not two eyes you're like oh
like this is what they need or this is
maybe how I can help or this is where
things need to change instead of what
typically happens is we're on our phones
and we see something we see a headline
and then we assume that we just know
what the answer is to fix it instead of
like
just getting involved somehow if you're
passionate about that cause and yeah
yourself in that situation to learn from
people who are actually in that
situation oh my gosh that's such a
golden nugget right there
yeah so I guess this is a great segue
then for like kind of to round out and
finish this discussion what advice do
you have for people listening who feel
stuck in their circumstances and have a
hard time believing in themselves and
their capabilities so you've talked a
lot about that's kind of been the theme
through the whole podcast but like just
to end it like what what would you like
to say to them as kind of like a final
encouragement I guess
I think the thing is this is that
there's there's two choices right you
can you can kind of count yourself out
and you can just assume that your life
is going to be like this forever and
it's going to always be hard and it's
going to suck
or you can develop this like whatever it
takes mentality which is kind of what I
had to do like after I got out of jail
where the odds were stacked against me
like I was a convicted felon I was like
newly in recovery like without being in
jail I had all this I had I had debt
I didn't my resume was very unattractive
being I had so many jobs all the world
like kind of stacked against me in a way
but I I was just willing to do whatever
it took whatever it took
I was like I just knew that if I could
do these certain things if I could work
out if I could stay away from drugs if I
could you know stay away from like the
certain people that were in a way like
indirectly like leading me to making bad
or influencing me to make bad decisions
if I could just take accountability
self-awareness like do all these things
it gave me a chance to win it gave me a
chance to get better
and then over time like what happens is
you get one day under your belt two days
three days and then you look back it's
like wow it's been a week and I've been
doing this right and so you can see
where I'm going with this and over time
you start to develop more
self-confidence to develop more
self-esteem and you start to believe in
yourself right because I think believe I
think believing in yourself
like doesn't come
from achieving the big thing
believing in yourself
comes from getting back up after each
time you fall believing in yourself
comes from continuing to persevere when
the odds are against you believing in
yourself comes from being able to keep
walking when things feel uncomfortable
and it just and just it's the person
listening to this if you're still alive
you're still here just know that you're
here for a purpose you're here for some
sort of meaning and that it doesn't
always have to be this way and just to
keep putting one foot in front of the
other and even though you can't see
light right now even though it seems
like really really dark in your
situation and the world seems against
you just keep moving forward one step at
a time one day at a time and then I
don't know when I don't know how but
light will come light will come but you
just have to keep believing in yourself
and focus on how far you've come and not
how far you have to go
wow that was so inspiring you're gonna
make me cry
I'm gonna blame it on my pregnancy
I'm doing two weeks you guys so
um thank you so much for sharing that
and thank you for sharing your story
it's very inspiring and I know you've
helped so many people so I appreciate
you coming on to my show and I hope it
resonates and isn't is really helpful
for a lot of people
well thanks Alan this has been awesome
and congratulations to you and all your
success and
kind of what you're doing to to shine
light in the world and um thanks for
having me and hopefully if you're
listening to this hopefully this
resonated with you hopefully you uh
we're inspired and also maybe like you
just got some nuggets so maybe some
things you can do differently if you are
in that place where you're you're
feeling like a victim or you're feeling
like
um like the world is against you I mean
I I've been there I get it and I know
what didn't help me what didn't help me
was feeling that way because it
essentially
counting me out of the game because I
just assumed my life was going to suck
forever so I just didn't even try and I
blamed everybody else for my problems
but when I started to take these small
steps like they started to add up into
like big changes and like just it could
just be as simple as like
going outside for a five minute walk
and then what happens you're gonna go
outside for that five minute walk and
you're gonna feel better you're gonna
come back in you're like wow like I'm
feeling better for two reasons one
because I'm doing something that I
probably knew I should have done a long
time ago if you're somebody who hasn't
gotten a lot a lot of movement in
two
maybe in previous days you would have
like reached for a beer or vegged out on
the couch watching Netflix to just kind
of check out and you're proud of
yourself now for using a healthy coping
mechanism to deal with life and three
you're going to get like the the
feel-good chemicals that come with
moving your body and so you're gonna be
like all right I want to do more of this
so maybe like the next week you do seven
minutes the next week you do ten and
then like three months go by and now
you've you've run a freaking 5K but did
it again did it start with you just
getting off the couch and going to run a
5k no it just started with five minutes
small goals
focus on what you can control
make sure that the people you're
spending time with are bringing the best
out on you and not just like patting you
in the back but checking you and
challenging you when you're acting out
of line never stop believing in yourself
know that you are going to do great
things and I think good things will
happen
amazing thank you Doug
cool I think this is a great place to
end it and I really appreciate
everything you shared thanks Ellen this
is awesome
[Music]